hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve count good nodes in a binary
tree this is according to leak code this
is microsoft's most asked question of
2021 so far and in my opinion it's
actually a pretty good problem to
understand a lot of good fundamental
knowledge can be gained from this
problem so we're given the root of a
binary tree that is going to always be
non-empty we want to count the number of
good nodes in the tree and a good node
is defined so for example take node x it
is defined as a good node if for example
let's take this node 4 if from the path
from the root node all the way down to
this node this path in particular if
there are no nodes in this path that
have a greater value than this
particular node so basically along this
path if there isn't any value larger
than 4 then this node 4 counts as a good
node what about 1 let's take the path
from the root to 1.
are there nodes greater than the value 1
along this path yes because this node 3
is greater than this node 1 so then 1 is
not a good node so we can solve this
problem in linear time big o of n time
where n is the number of nodes and
memory complexity is going to be log n
or in other words the height of the tree
which technically could be greater than
log n it could be as big as n
and we can accomplish this with a simple
tree traversal in particular we're going
to be using pre-order traversal meaning
when we recursively run dfs on this
we're going to process each node before
we do recursively the left subtree and
recursively the right subtree so the
first question is is the root node
technically a good node well
this is basically the entire path are
there any nodes greater than three no so
technically yes the root node does count
as a good note so what we're going to do
now we've counted one as
we found one good note and now we want
to know how many good nodes are there in
the left subtree and how many good nodes
are there in the right subtree well
first let's do the left subtree even
though we could do it in the opposite
order but i'm just going to do the left
first so
to count how many good nodes are in this
left subtree first we have to we have to
run the dfs on the left child but before
we do that we have to pass to this left
child we have to pass what's the
greatest value we have seen so far we
don't have to pass all the values we've
seen so far we just have to pass the
greatest because then we're going to
check for every node is this
is the greatest node that we've seen so
far somehow greater than this node if it
is then this is not a good node so to
this node we're gonna pass the value
three we're gonna now process this the
greatest we've seen so far is three one
is smaller than that this is not a good
node so this does not count but we still
have to recursively run dfs on the left
and right now when we do run dfs on the
left obviously it doesn't have a right
subtree but on the left subtree what
value are we going to pass here well we
would want to take the max of 3 which
was the parents max and the value here
of course one is smaller than three so
we're going to pass three to this uh
node as well so so far the max we've
seen is three
is is the max greater than this node
it's not so even though they're the
exact same value this still counts as a
good node so that's what we learned and
so
now we have seen two good nodes so far
now the same thing we're going to do on
the right subtree literally the exact
same thing just recursively doing the
same thing we're going to pass 3 to this
node because 3 is the max value we've
seen so far from the root right if there
was a really big value here we wouldn't
want to transfer it to the right subtree
but we're counting from the root
downwards so let's look at four is this
max value greater than four it's not so
then four does count as a good node
now let's do the same thing for the left
subtree but when we go to the left
subtree we're not passing three we're
passing four because so far now along
this path the max value we've
encountered is four so we're going to
pass four to this child node one now
obviously four is greater than one so
this does not count as a good node same
thing on the right node we're going to
pass 4 down to this node the max we've
seen so far is 4 but this value 5 is
greater than it 4 is not greater than 5
so this counts as another good node so
all together you can look we have one
two three four good nodes and
we would you know from the root what
would we actually do we'd say okay we so
far we found one uh good node at this
root in the left right plus left this is
basically the equation we're going to
use one plus left plus right of course
left is actually going to be one because
there's one good node in the left
subtree right is actually going to be
two there's two good nodes in the right
subtree so one plus one plus two that's
going to be four so from the root we're
going to return four good nodes in this
entire tree so with that being said we
can finally jump into the code okay so
we know this is going to be a recursive
function but in our recursive function
we're going to have to pass in more than
just the root so which is why i'm going
to define a separate function inside of
this function dfs obviously we're going
to pass in the node or the root or
whatever you want to call it but we're
also going to pass in what the max value
is so far from the path from the root
all the way down to every particular
node and i didn't mention this but our
base case of course is going to be if
the node we reach is null right so if
not node now what are we going to return
then does an empty tree have any good
nodes of course it doesn't so we're
going to return 0 right ok so now we got
to a node that is non empty we want to
know is this particular node a good node
or not well let's
let's compute that into our result so
we're going to say okay result is going
to be 1 if this node is a good note how
do we know if it's a good note if the
node value is greater than or equal to
the max value encountered so far
otherwise the result so far is going to
be 0 meaning this node is not a good
node next we want to do is update our
max value so far right we're just going
to take the max of itself and the max of
the current node's value so we've
updated our max value so far why did we
do this because of course we're going to
need to pass this along to our dfs
recursive call of course we're going to
run dfs on the node's left child passing
in the max value and of course we're
going to do the exact same thing on the
right child the right subtree passing in
the max value so far now what are we
going to do with the results of these
two recursive calls well this function
itself is just counting the number of
good nodes so we're going to take the
result of it and add it to our result
for both of these function calls we're
going to count the number of good nodes
in the left and right subtree adding it
to the result once that's been computed
then we can go ahead and actually return
that result value
so you can see that this dfs is
basically computing the result that we
want of course we want to compute it for
the entire tree so when we actually call
our dfs we're going to call it on the
root node now what default value can we
pass in for the max value so far well we
could pass in some kind of negative
infinity right or whatever but it
actually works out as well if we just
pass in the root value because as long
as this root is greater than or equal to
the max value so far it does count as a
good note and we know that the root node
always counts as a good node so this is
going to work out for us now what we
actually want to do is return the result
of this function call and then we're
good to go
as you can see it's pretty dang
efficient so this is a good fundamental
binary tree question to understand your
pre-order traversal and it also happens
to be the most common asked question by
microsoft of 2021 so i hope that this
was helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching